i think that there's
like what's your relationship like with
everybody in the crew
now because i feel like that kind of
felt like there might be some some
you know obviously you guys dropped the
no the record no reunions like
is there any static it's just a bunch of
us and we're not always on the same page
you know what i'm saying so
you know it's all love it's not it
wasn't like on some i i'm gonna put out
the album and as a diss you know what
i'm saying oh as a response it's like
okay i hear that they put not an album
let's do our own version since we can't
do uh i ain't get no phone call
but i'm not gonna lie a week before i
was releasing
jewels had called me you know what i'm
saying to get on the album but
this is before he was locked up by it
right oh yeah of course oh yeah
yeah shout outs to joel's he just came
home yeah he did shout out to him but um
it wasn't yeah it wasn't no static but
as far as now um
yeah i got no problems with no i spoke
to i spoke to jim i speak to joel's
you know me here and it seems like cam
is the one who
consistently cam is the one that messed
everything up nah [ __ ] what you know no
but it just seems
like he it feels like he's the guy who's
like i feel like jim and juelz are
always cool
i feel like it's always like a cam thing
at least from the outside looking in as
a fan like
yeah i mean you know cam is cam as cam
you know what i'm saying he's he's going
to move on his own time so
it is what it is do you know how he felt
about you guys doing that
about doing the project yeah no i don't
i don't know i heard from
from somebody that he probably mad at me
but you know so have you talked about
the killer um no i haven't no i haven't
but shout outs to kim you know what i'm
saying he's doing business with my guy
ryan
we got a whole cbd uh company coming out
or whatever
uh called legends at hump where we're
doing you know lines with different
legends or whatever
you know check out that it's coming soon